[Music]
when a person considers and analyzes the
functions of the brain the brain is
analyzing itself as far as the human
brain is concerned it is the only thing
on planet earth to have the ability to
become self-aware of its own existence
not only is the brain aware of its
existence
and it also spends its entire life
trying to understand why existing is not
enough for the brain the brain must also
understand why it is the single question
why that separates human from all other
species on planet Earth ever since we
are old enough to utter words it seems
as though our favorite word is why when
we are a child we ask things like why
the sky is blue or why things died our
parents might give us their best answers
but the spirit of our question remains
Restless and fundamentally unanswered
our brain is so confused it does not
understand how it can be both conscious
enough to ask questions but not
conscious enough to uncover all the
answers it taunts itself with this
perpetual cycle trying to find a way out
of its infinite madness but it only
knows how to dig itself deeper so what
do we do do we follow our brain into its
hole of madness yes and no we must be
careful when we live with the word why
because it is a double-edged sword on
one side it is a wasted existence to
disregard our inquisitive nature and not
try to improve life and human
understanding but on the other side
identifying with this infinite inquest
fills us with a sense of constant
dissatisfaction
and restrains us from ever truly
stopping and enjoying our individual
lives it is a balance between both sides
that we must learn and apply we must ask
why but learn how to live happily
without always having an answer for it
if our well-being is dependent on all
that wise being answered we become like
a dog chasing its own tail we will
constantly chase our brain running in
circles longing for all the answers to
life but once a dog catches its tail it
realizes that the tail was a part of it
the whole time and it has only bitten
itself in the same way people who try to
find the experience of life by merely
chasing after it suffer just like the
tail is attached to the dog life is
already attached to us we do not always
need to chase it sometimes we just need
to live it and enjoy its mystery